Welcome to Ear Biscuits,
the podcast where two lifelong friends
talk about life for a long time, I'm Link.
And I'm Rhett,
this week at the round
table of dim lighting,
we're gonna be talking about
our concert experiences.
This is pretty fresh
because one of the ways.
So fresh man.
That I have been sort of experiencing the.
I know the pandemic.
On lockdown.
Is not over
but in the way that it
has affected us so much
and keeping us from our
normal social interaction,
our normal social social situation,
the way I kind of have
broken the seal on that
is through concerts.
Yeah, that's a, I mean, that's a big one,
when you find yourself in a
really large group of people
and especially when,
okay, now none of them
are wearing masks,
it's like all right, this is a big moment.
How did it, did you find yourself?
What was the first concert?
What was the first one you went to?
Well, we went to that outdoor concert,
the Lord Huron concert.
That was last year.
That was last year, I think that was the.
It was outdoors so I
didn't really register.
And there weren't seats,
it was, so you were, you kind
of had your own little zone.
I mean, went to the John
Mayer show at The Forum
and then you went the next night,
he was there three nights.
I went the third night.
You went the third night.
I don't know if I went to any,
no, I went to the, a dating
company show, which was also.
Outdoors.
So yeah, Britanny took me to one of those.
But before that, I think
before the John Mayer concert,
we went to a Clippers basketball game.
I think the Clippers game.
You call them basketball
game's a concert now.
No, I'm just saying.
It's like a sport concerto.
Well, there was a performance
of the national Anthem
but I'm saying that for me was the first,
I'm in an enclosed space
with a lot of people
and that was basically,
that was right after LA
lifted the indoor mask mandate
and so and pretty much,
I would say 95% of people
were like thank God, I'm
not wearing my mask inside,
there were still a few people
but most people were like,
let's just get on with this,
I was definitely on team
I'm not wearing my mask inside this place,
I'm happy to be in here with all these,
seeing all these smiling faces.
I mean, we watched the
national championship
and I was talking to Christie about it
and she was, I was like,
look at all those people
and nobody's wearing masks and
then they cut to a shot of.
Roy Williams.
I was like, damn Roy Williams
is the only one wearing
a mask in the whole.
No, Roy Williams has been
wearing that same mask,
that very like decorative,
it's like he's been
wearing it the whole time.
Well, you know what?
Okay, good for him.
I was like, eh, good.
But yeah, concerts have definitely
been a symbolic threshold
that I've crossed
to say, I'm getting back into things,
like it's social on a whole new level
and so going back to concerts,
I've found myself having a new perspective
on concert experience,
something that I did not
appreciate before the pandemic.
So it's, yeah, 'cause you,
I mean, I'm so into music
but I've never really
been a concert person.
I would, when it comes
to listening to music,
I don't like listening to concert albums,
I've never gotten that.
Live albums tend to not do it for me.
I like the studio process,
I like the refining and the perfectionism,
even when it's like intentionally,
even if it recorded live and it's,
that's kind of the approach that they took
in whatever album of it
is, okay, this is a band,
you can tell that they're doing this live,
it's still presented, it's
still groomed and manicured.
And it's not that raw.
As intended.
And there's people who will say,
you don't really get so and so artists
until you see them live
and I've just never been
one of those people,
even though we can talk about
all the concert experiences we have,
I do feel like I'm turning over a new leaf
in terms of really appreciating
the communal experience
of being at a concert,
everybody's there for the same reason
or there might be a couple
of reasons people are there
but they're all positive,
they're all celebratory.
and at at least.
Unless somebody lost a bet,
there may be some people who are there
because they lost a bet.
That would suck, I've
never gone to a concert.
In any given concert.
As a punishment.
There is probably one
person there who lost a bet.
And there's definitely
people who are like,
I'm only here because my friend
didn't wanna come by themselves
but I don't even know who this
artist is kind of a thing.
but by and large, you've
got this group of people
that are into this artist
and with the type of artist
that we are both into,
it's a very, it's not
like an angsty experience.
No, in fact, I was noticing,
so in the course of two weeks,
I went to the John Mayer show at The Forum
and then The Bahamas show,
which it was at a, I can't
remember the theater,
it's a cool theater in
downtown but much smaller venue
and I was just noticing,
this is essentially the
same crowd, because.
Well, even that shirt you're
wearing, The Bahamas shirt
and it's got that eighties.
Yeah, he's kind of doing
the John Mayer SoBro kind of thing,
he does, it is much more funk focused
but it's still sort of
like middle aged white dude
with electric guitar playing
and kind of being in the
groove sort of music.
I would call him music
more groovy than funk but.
Yeah, so but one of the
things that I noticed,
because I like to sit down
at concerts, let me just
and I'll get into that
for a couple of reasons
but I was just noticing
that even at the most intense moments
of a John Mayer concert
and the most intense moments
of a Bahamas concert,
it's still a bunch of people
kind of going like this.
Just kinda nodding their
head, just a little.
Just moving their head.
Just a little bop.
There might be some
person who's like really,
there was a guy right
next to us in the balcony
at The Bahamas concert,
so we got into the balcony
so we could sit down at a table,
I was literally sitting
at a table and I was like,
this is how I want all concerts to be,
me at a table with my
family and a waitress.
Oh, you had a waitress.
Keep coming up and asking
what you wanna eat and drink.
I like that speed man,
especially for that kind
of show where it's like.
We did that at the Kacey
Musgraves show too at the Greek,
there's a little section
where you can sit at a table
and somebody will come
and get your food orders.
Yeah, you may know the
Greek, get me to the Greek,
I haven't seen that movie
but it's a great venue
right there in Los Feliz,
just a few blocks from
where we first lived in LA.
Some of my favorite concerts.
Outdoor amphitheater, that's a great spot.
It's a perfect venue.
At this point I'm such on this
concert wave that I'm like,
maybe I'll just, I'll buy
whatever the season pass
to the Greek is, there's
a lot of good people that.
I think this is a good idea
because I've noticed
it's a great night out,
it's, for our family we love to go
and I think this is true for you,
we love to go as a family
because we tend to all
like the same music,
like Locke went to John
Mayer all three nights
with different sets of people
and last night it happened
to be me and Shepherd
and then all four of us went to Bahamas.
He went to the Dead and Company.
Twice, three.
At least twice, maybe three times
'cause that was last Halloween.
And he, this is what he does,
he goes with a different group of friends
or a person each time he goes and he is,
a lot of times he's drawing some body in,
like these kids, 18 year old
kids don't like John Mayer,
you know what I'm saying?
Some do but yeah, so he's
bringing his friends to John Mayer
and they're like, I've
never really even listened
to anything that this guy
does, this is old man music
and then they're like but
hey, it's pretty good,
'cause when you see somebody
in concert and you're like,
well, I didn't know he could
play the guitar like that,
that's pretty impressive
and it's so different.
Oh, so you're doing the thing,
once, you gotta see him
live to really get it.
Well, I think one of the things
and we talked about this
in a previous episode
about the resurgence of the garage band,
that's what we called it.
Well, no, we talked about it in a carpool.
On the Mythical Society.
That's got to be.
A member of the society to hear that.
Those conversations.
The Car Biscuits.
We call it,
it's like a 20 minute version
of Ear Biscuits in a car.
So our prediction about the resurgence.
Every month.
The resurgence of garage
bands, almost as a rebellion
to the idea of someone just
kind of standing on a stage
with a track going, which
it can be incredible
and I respect and I am into on some level
but I don't go to those kinds of concerts,
I don't go to hip hop
concerts typically and you do.
I went to, well, first of all,
yeah, we as a family, all five of us,
'cause Lily came home early,
came back from college early,
she started her spring break a week early.
With so many classes still being online,
she was able to justify
coming home a week earlier
and then it just so happened
she could come to John Mayer's show
so like as a family,
we were all into that,
so it is cool for, I agree,
for us to go as a family
and we had a great time
but I went with Lincoln
and three of his friends
to the Trippie Redd show.
Different vibe.
Yeah, it was at the YouTube Theater,
which is attached to the SoFi Stadium,
which is in the same
parking lot as The Forum,
so it's like all in the same place
so this is a smaller, a
medium sized indoor venue
and yeah, we were wearing
masks at that point
and it felt a little weird
but that was a, I'd never
been to a hip hop show
and that was, I mean the opening
acts were kind of a joke,
just people jumping around and
not singing their own lyrics
while the backing track kind of
and other people on stage
kind of helped him out
but I mean, Trippie Redd
definitely commanded the stage
and it was just him.
I mean, there was no DJ on
stage, there was nothing else,
just a bunch of fog and like
a constant drone of an 808,
that like in between every single song.
It just keeps going.
It would this, the DJ who was in the wings
would just hit this low
drone that shook your,
all of your organs for,
until the next song started
and so sometimes he would,
Trippie Redd would walk around
stage or take his shoes off
or he would just be doing nothing on stage
and people were going nuts
and it was just this, like a OneNote,
just a constant, it's like an earthquake.
Yeah, that kinda like.
Between every single song.
Penetrates your soul.
Yeah that, so there was never a point
where my ears got a rest and I'm like,
should I have brought earplugs?
Possibly, they make those
ones that you can wear,
that you can still talk to people.
I have a pair, I've never
worn them to a concert
because the concerts I go
to are, they're not needed.
You put them in and.
That's a good, I should
have brought those,
Christie has some.
Christie has the same.
Because of her concussion.
It brings everything down to
an acceptable decibel level
but yet you can have a conversation
with a person next to you, it's magic.
Here's the hot tip that,
I can't remember who told us this
but if you don't take anything else
from this episode of Ear
Biscuits, you can remember this,
if you're in a super loud space,
if you're in front of
a speaker at a concert
and you wanna talk to
the person beside you
and they're yelling at the top
of their lungs in your face,
getting that spit all over
your face and in your ear.
Or getting right in your ear and yelling.
Getting right in your ear and yelling.
That's what most people do.
Which can really damage
your hearing even more,
all you gotta do, I wish I
knew who told us this trick,
you just take your finger,
don't put it in your ear,
take that little flap on the
front side of your ear hole
and push that in there
and then just lean in
and someone and then
you can tell the person,
hey, talk to me at a normal
volume, you don't have to yell.
They have to get close to your ear.
You gotta get close to the
ear like you're whispering,
just talk in a normal volume
and it's like a miracle.
Yeah, it somehow cuts through
the frequencies or something,
I don't know how it works
but you have to get everyone
in your group to agree to this,
in fact, I suggest a training session
before everybody goes into a concert,
it's like we're going
into a very loud place.
Dad mode activated.
And this, we're, this is
how we're all going to,
we're gonna speak to each other
as if we're hearing
something in an ear piece.
'Cause if you don't tell them
and they start yelling in your
ear and you cover your ear,
it's like, well, first of
all, they do get to hint,
that oh, he doesn't
want me to yell his ear
but also maybe he doesn't wanna hear me
'cause he is stopping.
We gotta, I gotta preempt.
This actually helps me
hear you, put this over,
put your finger over your ear
and speak in a normal voice.
There's a couple of
things that I've developed
that I've realized that now
that I'm going to concerts
as an adult, there's a few
things that have kind of changed
and things that I'm
embracing in my middle age
but we'll talk about that in a second.
And some things, I wanna go back
and talk about, I've written
down some concert memories
and a lot of them we were both there for,
so I'll see if you can
remember some of these things.
There are some pivotal experiences
that we had at concerts
and it sounds like we're
about to be concert daddies.
Emphasis on the daddy.
Hey, you just see us at the Greek,
we'll be there with our finger and.
Or just the dad, whoa, whoa, whoa, watch.
Where you going?
Hey, just.
Why are you lowering your seat man.
So that I can do it like this with no,
'cause it's just, I can do it with my.
No hands with it.
That's right.
Okay, that's enough hydraulic cheer.
But speaking of concerts,
we went to a Brooks and Dunn
concert back in the day and.
I'm gonna tell that story
but yeah, Brooks and Dunn is.
That was making the segue into this,
that's what I was doing.
Oh and this, you're
talking about this album
that we recorded?
Yeah, yet another reason to be a member,
a third degree member
of the Mythical Society,
every year for the past few years,
part of our quarterly collectibles,
one of them has been a
vinyl, an exclusive vinyl
and we love to just adopt or
find some music that we love
and then do our spin on it,
this is Brooks and Dunn in the year 3000.
You heard that right.
We took two, our favorite
Brooks and Dunn song, Neon Moon
and then everyone's most
popular Brooks and Dunn song,
Boot Scootin' Boogie and we created them
as if they were being
made for the first time
in the year 3000.
You have the first time.
Well, I mean.
It's like a, if we covered
them in the year 3000.
Covered them in the year 3000
or there was just another group
that was inspired by them,
I mean, I don't know,
we haven't really
established the backstory
but the music is supposed to sound
like it was in the year 3000
but it, they are authentic
covers of these two songs.
This is a fun project.
You gotta join Third Degree
of the Mythical Society
to get this exclusive collectible,
join Third Degree monthly
by the end of April, 2022,
that's this month, in
order to get this thing,
Neon Moon, Boot Scootin'
Boogie in the future.
That's how we do it,
you gotta be facing backwards on the back.
Pretty, pretty excited about
that, very excited about it,
it's a collectible item.
So one of the things
that has changed for me,
I was never a buy the t-shirt guy
but I have become a buy the t-shirt guy.
And wear it, look at you, you're wearing.
And I'm wearing it as a visual aid,
this is the, obviously
The Bahamas concert one.
What did you realize,
'cause I've had some
thoughts about this too.
Well, two things.
What happened?
Two things, kids, so kids
happened a while back
but you wanna, you're the dad
and you wanna get your kids
something to remember the concert by
and this is gonna sound weird to you
but one of the things that
has actually changed for me
is the way that I am
viewing t-shirts in general
on two levels, stay with me here,
one is, very recently
but also very rapidly,
my relationship with
t-shirt fit has changed
and it's really just a response
to the changing styles,
meaning that if you go
back like eight, nine years
and you look at Good Mythical Morning
and you look at some of the stuff we shot,
our t-shirts were so freaking tight,
I mean, you had some that was so tight
they looked like they were painted on
and I was right behind
you, not quite as tight
but we were wearing some tight t-shirts.
It made me feel secure.
I was wearing a medium
as, a short sleeve medium
and you were wearing.
A short sleeved small.
I guess I was wearing small.
Yes and then we transitioned to,
you were wearing a medium
and I was wearing a large,
like if we were wearing our own merch,
I was wearing a large and
then in the past few months,
I've just like quickly gone back to an XL,
which is, it's really a
response to the styles changing,
so the effect that that had on me
being able to buy a t-shirt at a venue
is like, I can just pick the XL
and it's gonna be a little bit bigger
but when you're wearing a
shirt that has to fits tightly.
There's forgiveness, yeah,
there's no forgiveness.
The fit has to work really well
and it has long enough for me
but I'm just like, I'm gonna get the XL,
so I just walk up and I
pick the design I want
and I'm just say XL and
I just walk out with it.
So you always wanted to get a shirt
but you never felt eligible.
I don't like t-shirts,
I don't like going to
a site on the internet
and picking t-shirts that
have designs that I like,
it's, I don't know why,
it's kind of stressful
and I just, I don't wear that
kind of t-shirt very often
but I like buying t-shirts
that are connected to things
that have happened,
so like if Locke and I are on a road trip
and we stop at a restaurant
and they have a t-shirt,
I'm gonna get that t-shirt
'cause it's like a memory from that place
and obviously concerts are the
perfect opportunity for this.
It's a good souvenir.
So I've changed my whole
relationship with them,
so now if we go to a concert,
even if I'm just going
to a concert with Jesse,
I'm probably gonna get a t-shirt,
XL, the one in the corner, XL.
And if you see somebody on the street
who went to the show
and they see your shirt,
they pretty much know
that you were at the show
because they'll sell,
they don't usually sell
that merch online, you can
only get it at the show,
so it's this insider type
thing that I've also got.
You gotta have the tour exclusive stuff.
Yeah, I'm feeling that.
So that's a big change in my life,
is A, buying t-shirts with stuff on them,
I mean, I'm embracing that and
B, buying concert t-shirts.
The thing about buying tickets
is that they're still really expensive,
I mean, especially if you're
taking your whole family,
that's the thing that
I'm still getting over
and then realizing where,
like there's all the,
getting used to the mad rush
of getting a good ticket
when they first are released,
making sure you can master
the art of securing a
ticket in the right spot,
'cause I like more of
a balcony where I can,
well, I've never been down on the floor,
I don't think I'm ready for that.
Now, I know for you and
your tallness and stuff,
there's but for me, I'm just,
I like to have the option to sit down
and I don't wanna be forced
to stand the whole time,
I mean, if it's a smaller
venue and there's like,
there's no seats down there in the pit,
it's like that makes me, I don't know,
that's a bit, that's a lot
to be down there in that,
I'm not to that point yet.
I'm more of a lay back and enjoy.
I think I would be okay with standing
but from a very, I'm
saying all of my adult life
and definitely since high
school, every, any type of crowd,
it doesn't matter what's
happening but concerts apply,
they fall under the umbrella of a crowd
and people watching
something, being six, seven,
every single decision that
you make about placement
and posture is filtered through
being that big of a person
and now being that big of a person
with this much hair as well.
Oh wow, they can't even
look over your shoulder.
So I am so conscious about this
and it actually can ruin
an experience for me
if I get a bad seat and I'm in a place
where every, oh,
everybody's standing up now
and I've gotta stand up.
So what happened,
obviously what I'm saying
is that if I stand up,
whoever's behind me and
usually two rows behind me
and like three people wide,
they can't see anything
and I don't like being that guy,
so at The Bahamas, at
the John Mayer concert,
at The Forum, of course,
there's the standing room
down on the floor and then there's.
Actually they were seats.
But they all stood up the whole time.
But they all stood up
the whole time, yeah.
But then there's the balcony
and we were on the second
row, I wanted to get first row
but we got, it was a last minute decision
so we got second row
and I was like, dang it.
'Cause if you got first of
row, you could stay seated.
Stay seated the whole time.
The whole time.
Nobody in front of you.
Regardless of what happens.
So we get there and then John comes out,
immediately, two girls
in front of us stand up
and so I hear the woman
behind me, he was very vocal,
said a lot of funny
things about John Mayer
and how sexy he was and what
was happening to her body
every time he picked up a new guitar.
Oh really?
Yeah, she would be like,
F John Mayer, F me, can you F me,
yeah, stuff like, not
asking him to do that,
just like, she's like oh,
John Mayer, you are so sexy.
She was saying that stuff?
And she was with a dude,
like her husband, I mean.
Just verbally processing
her sexual frustration.
She's like oh no, now
you've got the green guitar,
oh, F John Mayer, she was
really into John Mayer,
When he picked up that JoBro like thing,
that was, she lost it.
She lost it.
Oh, you're so sexy John Mayer.
Her water broke.
Well, some things
happened so but she says,
this is the first thing
I heard out of her mouth the whole night,
she says, oh no, we're not standing up,
that's what, as soon as these girls,
'cause this is a bunch
of middle aged people
and there's some, like not
20 year old girls stand up,
oh no, we're not standing,
oh, not standing up.
Give me a break, how can
you be that into somebody
but then not wanna stand up for them?
Well, because the
reverberation of the stand,
I was on team not, I
wasn't gonna stand up,
I didn't stand up,
so, okay, I was that guy
but I made my son do it.
We definitely stood up.
Well, here's what I said.
We were a little further back than you.
Nope, they were the only
people that stood up
and then there was a resistance
to sitting up, to standing up
and then I leaned over to Locke
and I said, Locke, tap
on that girl's shoulder
and ask her if she can sit down,
yeah, I was like, I'm just
gonna try it, I'm like.
You're gonna get him to try it.
I'm gonna get him to try it,
because a 18 year old kid asking
is different than a dad asking
and so, and he was fine with it
because he was feeling the vibes
and what people were saying behind us
and he taps on her
shoulder, she turns around
and I see, I guess, I
couldn't hear what he said
but she looks at him and shakes her head
and just keeps standing up
and I said, what did she say?
She said, no, I was like, okay, all right.
I'm on team keep standing.
So let me tell you what
I did the whole concert.
That's tough though, it is tough.
They stayed standing,
I stayed seated the entire
concert until the last song.
Yeah, 'cause you're different.
Because I was like and so I kind of like.
You're so much taller.
Shepherd got a little bit shafted
because he was more blocked by them
and so Shepherd would, Shepherd and Locke
would stand up quite a bit,
they stood up the whole time
and then Shepherd and Locke would stand up
when everybody else stood up
and I would never stand up,
because I'm almost standing
up anyway when I'm seated
and then I would kind of
lean around these girls
and kind of, I could see half of the band,
one whole half of the stage,
didn't see it the whole
night until the end
and then I could see the screens,
the screens are great in The Forum.
Well, I guess.
But I can't do it.
Maybe I'll backtrack a little bit.
'Cause I don't wanna do what
that girl was doing to me.
To fifteen people behind me.
'Cause here's the thing.
They bought a premium
seat for sitting down.
Switch seats with me for God's sake,
I'll sit on the front row and sit down,
It's no different to you.
Yeah, I don't know why,
I mean, I know why they were standing,
because they're really into it
and that's how they get into it.
It's like saying,
I guess in their minds
it's like going to a party
and saying, hey, don't dance at this party
or don't listen to this music
or don't have a good time.
If you're going to a John Mayer concert
and you and wanna stand, get
stand, get the floor seats,
that's all I'm saying,
get the floor seats.
I mean, they're expensive
but I think that if getting
this seat that needs to be a,
is for people who wanna sit,
I think that's the
complicating factor here.
I'm sensitive to the fact
that people want to stand up
and enjoy a concert and
kind of dance and whatever
but my guess and my choices
as a six, seven person
become the back row of the
top, which I'm not gonna do
'cause I'm not gonna sit there
or the back row of the
bottom and it's like that's.
Did Jesse stand up?
Because she's short or.
She wasn't at John Mayer,
it was just me and the boys.
But did Shepherd stand
up so that he could see?
Yeah.
And Locke stood up.
But he was still blocked a little bit but.
And then the woman, the
vocal woman behind you,
did she stand up?
Very reluctantly, a couple
of times she'd be like,
oh no, we're standing up,
that's what she would say,
the same woman that was just losing her,
at John Mayer's sexiness.
That doesn't add up to me.
I was like, ah.
Unless there's some sort of condition
or reason that she can't stay standing.
No, I think it's just
because it's just like,
hey, I'm enjoying this and I'm
here and I'm in the moment,
I don't have to stand up to.
I used to be that way and
now I'm like, you know what?
Stand up, get your body
moving, really engage in it,
I was dancing, man, I was
moving all over the place.
Oh, I know your type,
I, there's like, I'd see like one out of.
I was loving it.
One out of like 40 people
at a concert is your type,
it's like that guy is either on drugs
or just a certain type of personality.
I wasn't moving like I was
in another drug universe
Or something.
No, the guy next to me.
At The Bahamas concert.
I've seen that.
Who literally, he and his partner.
Another dimension.
They had a table with the
waitress and everything,
I was like, there's no
need to stand up brother
but he was just, I mean,
he was like, it was like,
you might, you feel like
you might get hit by him
if you were close to him,
I was glad that I was
two seats away from him.
It was like he was trying
to shed his own skin
like a snake.
Yeah and I was just like,
man, you're also with me here
and it's, you're making it a lot about you
and I'm trying to focus on this
and it's like, somebody
is like directing traffic
in an alternate universe right next to me.
Well, I mean Dead and
Company, you see it all,
I mean, there are, it's
multi-generational,
which is interesting, so is
John Mayer, multi-generational
but it's also multi like
substance, man it's crazy.
Those people have a great excuse.
Yeah but I just don't,
I mean, it is fun to give
yourself over to dancing
but you are an exception,
because you know that you're
inconveniencing people,
you're blocking so many people,
so you have to get that
front row seat man.
If I go to a concert
and everyone is standing
or if I'm in a lawn situation.
Do you hunch?
No, where people are standing,
I just stand up and I'm like,
some people are gonna deal
with this and it will be fine.
It's not your fault,
people know it's not your
fault you're that tall
but I did see on the Reddit forums,
'cause I was looking at
what people were saying
about the John Mayer show afterward,
the most hardcore fans
are the ones that are,
they give them the hardest time
about picking apart the set list
and this night was better than that night
and all that stuff but then
people were also posting,
this was my view
and it was just a tall
person in front of them,
so it's like, very well could
have been you if you stood
so you did the right thing staying seated,
you took one for the team,
those girls in front
of you didn't do that.
I don't, yeah, I can't come
down on one side or another.
I feel like.
I think it's their right.
To stand but not yours.
Every time I'm in a space like that,
I feel like there's
gotta be a different way
to design spaces.
I mean, what if you just stood up but,
in a lot of the photos
that we take together,
you'll stand up and then you'll
just spread your feet apart.
Yeah but that's problematic too,
'cause you got people in and
you're, it's very small area.
Even if it's your family,
so your family is basically
standing in front of your thighs
as you're spreading for two hours.
Yeah, I can't do a air
chair for that long.
Not a air, a spread is
different than an air chair.
I mean but if I'm
standing up, I am moving,
I don't, I'm not like my,
there's like if I was
inside of a cylinder,
I don't know how big
that cylinder would be,
there's movement that
happens within that cylinder
but my hands and stuff don't escape.
Oh my hand, yeah.
From the cylinder and stuff.
When it comes to dancing,
yeah, I agree with this cylinder.
It's kinda like you, like the
beam me up pod on Star Trek,
you gotta stay within that thing.
You stay inside that.
That's your space.
Yeah, I mean this whole, I mean,
I don't even wanna get into the.
I keep my fists up by my collarbones.
Into the mosh pit thing.
I keep my pit, mY fist by my
pits, one of these things.
I've seen that move.
'Cause it's like and
it's more in the torso.
But you wouldn't be into a mosh situation,
like that, the whole, the swing.
I'm too old for that man.
But at no point in my life,
at no point in my life,
was I ever into the idea of
getting the arm in the face,
like an, I don't understand the appeal.
Well, I'll tell my experience with that,
so this was senior year
in high school, had to be,
so Kurt Cobain had passed away
and then Dave Grohl
started the Foo Fighters
and then they released their album,
so this was probably, I guess
this was like 96 and maybe 97
and they had a show at the,
I think it was The Ritz in Raleigh
and the, let's see, I wasn't dating,
yeah, it was pretty in senior year
because I wasn't dating my
girlfriend, who was my girlfriend
for senior year and
freshman year of college
but this, the other girl that I,
another girl that I would
take home from school,
I took Candace home from
school and she was a sophomore,
she was the same age as the
girl that I was interested in
and who would later become my girlfriend
and then so I and so I was
talking to her about the show
and the Foo Fighters have a show
and she was like, I wanna go
and I was like, okay,
let's go to this show
and we were just friends.
I don't know if she was interested in me
but she also knew that I
was interested in her friend
and then whenever we decided to go,
which is a strange thing,
looking back on it,
like the two of us were
gonna go to this show
but very early on, I was
like, I wanna invite so and so
and maybe we had started dating
or maybe we were about to start dating
but this was very early
on and so it was like,
then this, it was basically Candace's idea
to go to this show but then
it was my idea to bring,
I'll just say she was my
girlfriend, I can't remember the.
Can't remember her name.
I can't, it was, I can't
remember the chronology of it
but it was basically first,
second or third date.
I was like, oh, I wanna bring her,
so it was the three of us who went
and it was, even though
it was Candace's idea,
she became the third wheel
and we go to this show
and we go so early and there's
no seats in this place,
it's one of those like black box theaters
and you cram in, literally
everybody crammed in,
I don't remember there
being an opening act
but it was, I mean, this is like on the,
Dave Grohl, Foo Fighters on the
heels of, Nirvana's no more,
this is all we've got, this
is the new version of Nirvana
and so we will show up and
people just started packing in,
packing in, packing in,
and we were about four people back
from the front of the stage and.
Just general admission.
Yeah and we waited there for
probably an hour and a half,
waiting for the show to start
and more people kept showing up
and they kept packing us forward
and it was like, we
started getting smushed,
smushed, smushed, smushed
and it started getting hot.
I hate this feeling.
And it was the type of
thing where it was so tight
that you couldn't, you
were shoulder to shoulder,
chest to back everywhere and they started,
the security guards,
after an hour of this,
they started handing out water bottles.
Sometimes they would just
fling the water on everybody,
it was like, it felt postapocalyptic
and then they would hand water bottles
and people would be
guzzling water bottles,
just like, just dying of thirst
and you would just hand it around,
I was drinking water out of water bottles
after somebody else drank half the bottle.
Just to survive.
I didn't even know who they were,
for me to do that you
know we were desperate.
But it was the nineties,
it was before germs.
And then they, Foo Fighters came out
and they started playing
and then there was another press forward
from like way in the back,
everybody wanted to get to the front
but there was no way to do that
and we were smushed so close,
it was, you couldn't breathe
and then I looked over there and Candace,
just all of a sudden I was looking at her
and all of a sudden, boop,
she dropped, she was gone.
That, this is such dangerous man.
And since we were so close to the front,
we and some other people waved,
said, hey, we need some
help and we picked her up
and she wasn't unconscious
but she was very woozy and not with it
and we put her over the barricade
and gave her to a security guy
who then took her away and.
There she goes.
There goes the third wheel.
I'm like, well, no more.
Hope she gets home.
No more third wheel, I'm just here
and I was like, I mean, that was so,
I'm so embarrassed that
we did not follow her.
What are the ethical?
It was just like she was
gone before we knew it.
If a third wheel of a date drops
and is being taken care
of by professionals.
She's being taken care
Can you just move on?
I mean, I don't know
if you should feel bad.
Was I supposed to jump over the barricade?
If this person is a designated third wheel
and the third wheel, by definition,
if you're riding a bicycle
and the third wheel falls off,
you can keep riding,
that's why they're called.
The third wheel.
Tricycle to a bicycle.
It's unnecessary, you
know what I'm saying?
It's not that I was thinking that.
If you feel the third
wheel is taken care of,
you can keep riding.
I mean I did.
And you did, you shouldn't
feel bad about it.
I'm sorry Candace, I'm
sorry for what we did
but I didn't mind being pressed
against my new girlfriend.
That was nice.
That was nice, It's just like,
okay, it's like we're kind of skipping
the holding hands thing
entirely 'cause I'm,
every part of my body is pressed up
against the back of your body.
Well, you had to make a choice though,
because if you're side by side,
you're both pressing against strangers.
So you must be behind her.
Oh, I got behind her.
What, did you get in front of her?
No, because once I got behind her,
there was no getting in front,
once you were in a spot.
Oh yeah, you were locked in.
You were locked in
and yeah, so I was kind of
protecting her from the crush.
I just think it happened so quickly,
I wasn't making, my brain
wasn't fully formed.
Yeah, until 26.
And I was dehydrated
and I'm not proud of it.
She ended up being okay.
But how long, how much
later did you convene?
I believe it was after this show,
so that the entire show, she was kind of.
Where was she?
She was, she recovered
and then she was kind of in the back,
we didn't have cell phones.
That's why they could just
throw water all over the crowd,
no phones to worry about.
I mean, my girlfriend was her friend,
so it was just as much on
her, we were just bewildered,
didn't know what to do.
I hate that I've.
It was scary.
I've never been, the
closest I've ever been
to that circumstance
was actually when state beat Florida state
and we all rushed the field,
Chuck Amato was like first year
and everybody was getting
up on the goalpost
to bring it down and I was in this crowd
and I was like and first of all,
as a tall guy, you actually
have an advantage here,
you don't feel like you're,
you can see over everybody's
head but even then,
I was like, I just feel like
I could fall and get trampled
and then the goal post,
whoever was on the goal post,
the lots of people, it comes down
and this is back when they didn't make
the breakaway goal posts, this
is before they started making
the ones that they just
collapsed at the end of the games
or whatever or you can't bring them down,
this giant goal post comes down
and literally is coming down,
I've moved my, I'm locked into position
but I move my head out of the way
and it bounces off my chest
and it falls on the ground.
What, that's crazy.
And it was like and then we just saw,
then I just pick it up
and we start carrying it
to Hillsborough street but I felt so.
I wasn't there for that.
Vulnerable in that and so I've never,
if I sense that happening in a, I don't,
the thing is I don't go
to the types of shows
where that is a phenomenon
'cause I'm a middle aged dad
so and Locke goes to hiphop shows
but he just goes with his friends
and I'm like, you just, you can do that.
At Trippie Redd, there
was an open mosh pit area
and people were trying to mosh
but they weren't good enough at it
and there wasn't quite enough people
to form a tight enough space
to then create these mosh pockets
and in the Foo Fighters, it was so tight
that people were trying to
mosh but it wouldn't happen,
there was some crowd surfing
and then at the very end,
they went into this whole
10 minute feedback driven,
start to destroy their equipment thing,
which was pretty amazing to be a part of.
Years and a couple of years later,
I saw 311 at the same place,
it wasn't quite as crazy.
We actually saw No Doubt there too.
I was there for the No Doubt show.
We saw the No Doubt show.
In the back.
That was Tragic Kingdom album,
their first album and they were huge.
Still playing in clubs basically.
Don't Speak, all that, all
of those, Spiderwebs, all,
that was a fun show but I
guess, yeah, when my girlfriend,
we left, we made it out, Candace was okay,
hopefully she didn't tell her parents
about how much of an a-hole I was
but the companion story to that
is the concert at Campbell University,
Campbell University would
have these Christian bands
come into Dietrich auditorium
and we would just show up
and go to some of these shows
and a little bit later as Wax Paper Dogz,
we would perform at one of the.
Festivals.
One of the Christian music festivals
that was smaller time but I remember
there was a group of
people up there watching,
I think it was Third Day.
Yeah, Third Day came to Campbell.
And I don't know, I was in the back
and I was chewing gum and
my girlfriend was there
and she was somewhere
but we weren't together at this point
and I was kind of in the
back, maybe you were there,
do you remember this concert, Third Day?
I was at the Third Day concert.
We were there, we were probably
hanging out in the back
where you could be in a
seat, you could sit down,
you weren't up front
where there was a lot of
people pressing together
and I just, I don't know
why I did this again,
I guess I wasn't tall.
I didn't realize that this
was the Third Day concert
where you did this.
I was done with my gum
and instead of putting it
behind my ear, swallowing it
or you know what, putting
it in a receptacle.
Or just continuing to chew it.
Or just chewing it.
Until a later point.
Until you see a trashcan.
I took it outta my mouth
and I had the gum in my hand
and then I just, I don't know.
I didn't really think about things,
I don't think that I had a, there was no,
it wasn't an active decision
besides just being an asshole I guess
and I took the gum and I just threw it
towards the front, into the crowd.
I threw it into the crowd,
I don't know, again, it's like,
I have no defense for
this, I was, I don't know,
it was just like a teenager,
that's as bad as I got,
like ooh, I'm so bad,
look at me, I'm throwing my
gum and a bunch of Christians
and I'm also a Christian, so
hey, we're in this together
and then a few minutes
later or a while later,
I did find my girlfriend
and we were hanging out
and she was, she said, you
wouldn't believe what happened,
somebody threw gum in my hair.
Outta all the people
up there at the crowd,
I threw the gum on my
own girlfriend's hair
and I did not tell her that I did.
You never told her?
I'm pretty sure I didn't, man.
You never, at any point in
your relationship told her.
This is one of those stories that I've.
I told this story.
You've told story somewhere.
Eight years ago, six years ago
and I wonder if at that
point I remembered more
and I did tell her but my recollection
is that I never told her that
I threw that gum in her hair,
because if I'm an asshole
enough to throw gum,
I'm also an enough to not own up to it
when it lands in my girlfriend's hair.
Did you, was it currently in her hair
or was she like, I got it out, I've been,
that's what I've been doing
for the past 20 minutes.
You know what?
I don't remember, I
don't remember that part.
I found some peanut butter
at the convenience stand.
It might, I'd like to think
that it wasn't in so deeply that.
It didn't work.
It wasn't like it was a toddler's hair.
It was like, oh, what was that?
It was like, oh gosh and then.
Yeah and she pulled it outta
the five strands of hair
on the surface of her head.
Whose gum is this?
So now, I apologize to
her too, I don't know,
it's like, so concerts
brought out the worst in me.
The thing is, is that by telling her,
it probably would've made
her feel better in one sense,
because this is like when you're gross out
by somebody's gum and their saliva,
it could be, oh, that's
my boyfriend saliva,
I'm gonna get some of that later.
But why did you do that?
That's not a big deal.
Who am I dating?
I definitely had to have a sense
that this could make or
break a relationship,
like talk about showing your true colors.
'Cause then you had to explain yourself.
And there's no explanation.
So, that makes me think about the,
we definitely went through,
just because of the
culture that we were in,
we went to christian music concerts
and christian music, sort
of festivals and stuff.
Now we always had this,
we set in judgment over Christian music
even when we were in a Christian band.
'Cause we had taste.
Yeah, we thought that.
By and large, it was not,
it was like two bit ripoffs.
It was ripoffs of a lot of things.
Of whatever was popular,
with cringey Jesus lyrics.
I remember, so once we
started the Wax Paper Dogz
and we started getting a, we
were heavily influenced by 311
once we started trying
to write our own music,
we were bleaching our hair,
we were wearing the big jeans.
The most worthy of influences.
And writing, I was
writing rifs on the guitar
that I thought were approximations of 311,
they were very distant
approximations of 311
but we were having a hell of a time,
I mean, we were really
and so we would go to these places
and we went to one place
not to play but as fans,
'cause Tooth and Nail Records
was a thing, remember that?
Tooth and Nail Records may
still be a thing but that was a.
They had like alternative bands.
MxPx.
That were pretty, they
were more legitimate.
MxPx was a punk band
that was kind of like.
Are they Christian are they not?
Well, NOFX was a very well known punk band
that then, okay, so then it's okay,
let's do our Christian version of that,
MxPx instead of NOFX.
But also, we also had a little bit of.
You had a lip ring.
A judgemental eye towards
Tooth and Nail bands
because the way that we
would do our music is,
it was pretty explicit,
I mean, musically, it
was all over the place,
lyrically, it was also all over the place
but it was pretty explicitly christian
and then we would do
invitations at our concerts
just to, I know we
talked about this before
but just to remind you,
that's when at the end of your concert,
you start getting very serious
and the music gets very serious
and then Link in this case,
who was the lead singer,
would begin to and just, you know this man
and just think about giving
17 year old Link Neal,
the one that was throwing
gum in his girlfriend's hair,
the responsibility of
speaking off the cuff
about Jesus and God and
the plan of salvation
and then offering an opportunity
for people to make a decision
for Christ in the moment,
I so wish we had videotape of this
but that's how we did our concerts.
So I don't know why we
looked down our nose at MxPx,
because they were legitimately talented.
We looked down our nose
at them, not musically,
we looked down our nose
at them a little bit in
or maybe side eye to be like,
are these guys legit Christians
or are they just kind of like.
California Christians.
Yeah, I mean, how
Christian are these guys?
So what do you remember about the show?
I remember going to the MxPx show
and there was other
bands that were playing,
surprisingly, not a lot of people there
and then I just remember
going to the bathroom.
Yeah, that's what I remember.
And the lead singer was
pissing at a urinal.
And so were we.
And so we did too.
Do you remember saying something to him
while he was pissing?
'Cause I don't think I would've done that,
I've had people do that
to me many times but.
I probably did, yeah,
I was like, I don't know what I said.
Hey man, love your music.
Something nice.
How's your wiener?
Something.
Shaking it.
An insincere compliment.
That's all I remember about that,
the Tooth and Nail of it all,
I do remember going to Carolyns
for the christian music day
and Audio Adrenaline was
headlining that festival
and I remember being really
into the music that day,
'cause you're kinda in this
youth group setting, but boy.
Yeah, they were good, it
was pouring down rain.
No but I have but it was covered,
the venue at Carolyns was largely covered
so we got under that partly.
I remember already being soaked.
But don't you remember
that song, Big Big House?
Yeah, with lots and lots of room,
a big, big table with lots of food,
a big, big yard where
we can play football,
a big, big house, it's my father's house.
This a song about heaven
that seems like it's for preschoolers.
But here's the thing,
I feel like I can stand
up for them a little bit
because if you go back
and listen to this song,
it is like the cheesiest
song you can imagine
and you can't imagine any
teenagers ever being into it,
however, so much of nineties
music was like that,
even the non-Christian stuff.
I mean, musically, they had
chops as far as I remember.
The lyrics in nineties music
with the very few exceptions
was just so, like just,
I wrote this on the back of
a napkin three seconds ago.
But we didn't listen to christian music,
we listened to secular
music, we listened to 311,
we tried to, we're gonna emulate them
but we're gonna do this legitimately
in a Christian band circle
but I remember going to
freshman year in college,
Incubus came, they were
releasing their second album
and I had discovered them the year before
and we started emulating them in the band.
And this was kind of weird
because we were sort of
peaking in our Christian,
not peaking but we were
getting to a very high level
of sincere Christian commitment,
in that every area of our lives
was affected by our sort
of commitment to Jesus.
Oh yeah, so but I was
a huge fan of Incubus,
I knew that the.
Which literally means the demon that comes
and screws you when you're sleeping.
Yeah but the, I knew that the man,
this picture of the guy from
the seventies on the cover
of their albums was the
lead singer, Brandon's dad,
I had done my internet research,
that's the only reason
I used the internet,
was to look at band's
websites, I was like, man.
Band's dads.
They're coming to Mission
Valley, really small venue
and then I went there,
we watched the show,
this, Brandon still
had dreads at the time,
you went to the show with
me but then I was like,
I'm gonna hang out, I wanna meet him,
I wanna talk to him and
so I waited a while.
I remember this.
I waited for a long time and then,
actually, maybe I went early
'cause I remember it being daylight,
it had to have been daylight,
it had to have been early,
so I go early and I'm hanging around
and then I see him
walking around and he's,
there's a laundromat on
the other side of the venue
and he's going to do his
laundry from the tour bus
and I meet Brandon and
I start talking to him
and I talk to him for a long time
and my goal was to talk
about Jesus with him.
I wanted to save the lead
singer of incubus' soul,
because I was such a huge
fan, how wholesome is that?
Does that make up for me being an asshole?
Actually, that is sort of
very assholish in on itself.
Yeah, in a way it is but
I cared about him so much
and I liked him so much
but I wanted to, I knew that the only way
I could connect with him is
if he thought I was cool,
so I didn't ever really talk about Jesus.
I got this friend, man, he's
got long hair and a beard.
I asked him about his spiritual beliefs
and he was very nice.
He's kind of a hippy.
And he talked to me for, it
could have been an hour, man.
I remember you telling me
about this conversation
'cause I was not present
for, I went to the concert
but I didn't go to the conversation.
It was awkward, man, it was awkward.
It probably would've been
shorter if I'd have been there,
hey, we got somewhere to be.
I think I got his email address.
You still got the lead singer
of Incubus' email address?
Yeah, maybe.
You should use it.
I mean, I need to dig
up my Hotmail account.
Are they still an active band?
Yeah, I mean they got
much bigger after that
with their third or fourth album.
Well, speaking of band's dads,
just a little sidebar here,
Post Malone's dad tweeted,
he was like, here's a little
something to brighten your day
and it was our GMM episode.
Oh really?
Yeah, so he's like.
That's hilarious.
I just love the fact that his.
His dad tweets.
Yeah, he doesn't have that many followers
but he's very proud of his boy and.
I gotta look at that.
But I was thinking about going even,
well, the first concert
I remember is with,
my dad taking me to Beach
Boys at Walnut Creek,
so Walnut Creek ended up being kind of,
I think it kinda changed
our lives in a lot of ways,
'cause they built Walnut Creek.
New venue, outdoor amphitheater
on the edge of Raleigh.
And now all these big bands
had an excuse to come to Raleigh
in a way that maybe they
weren't coming before,
I don't know, maybe they were just going
to Dorton Arena in Fayetteville,
there wasn't a place
for people to play music
that I remember.
Unless it was like Carter
Finley stadium, like huge
but yeah, Dorton Arena
back in the seventies
and it's in Raleigh had like Led Zeppelin.
You know who else has played Dorton Arena?
We have.
Red Link.
And Merle Haggard who we saw there twice.
The Beach Boys were playing and of course.
You were young.
I was in seventh or eighth
grade and went with my dad
and John Stamos was the drummer,
I don't know if you remember.
Don't know Jesse.
I don't know how long he did that gig
but he would drum for the beach boys,
it was kinda like John Mayer playing,
being the lead of Dead and Co
but not really anything
close to that but so.
Did, you thought it was awesome though.
I thought, of course.
This is Kokomo days.
'Cause Full House was still happening.
No, it wasn't.
In seven, in 19, okay, when did it,
Full House had just gone
off the air in 1991, 1990.
I don't know, maybe you're right.
1990, I don't know, man, it might.
Did they play Kokomo?
Of course they did.
That was, I mean that was a big thing.
I just remember, so the cool
thing about Walnut Creek
is the lawn, I never, I
actually don't remember
ever sitting in the seats,
it was always the lawn seats, lawn.
'Cause you could get a
ticket for like 30 dollars.
Yeah and my dad and I are in the lawn
and there are these
two increasingly drunk,
middle aged ladies next to us
and then I don't remember
exactly how it happened
but my dad and I just end up
slow dancing with both of them.
What, are you serious?
Yeah not, just sort of just
like having a good time
and not for that many songs
but it just was something
that just happened
and it was, they were.
Did you and you never spoke
of it again, kinda a thing.
It was just like, hey, we're just kinda.
Did Diane hear about this?
Of course she did, it wasn't like,
so it wasn't a scandalous thing,
it was just a kind of a fun thing.
It was kind of like the
community square dance
where everybody can dance together
and you're gonna go back,
you're gonna ride your own
saddle back home kind of thing.
And it didn't get,
it never turned sexual even on any level,
it was just very much just
like, this is a bit crazy.
But I know how you thought as
a seventh and eighth grader.
Well, what do you mean?
Yeah but I wasn't thinking
about middle aged ladies
at that point.
You weren't?
I'm talking, these ladies
were in their fifties.
Oh, okay, alright, I remember the.
There's nothing wrong with that now,
I'm 44 but I'm just saying when I was 13.
The first concert I remember going to was,
my mom took me and you to see.
MC Hammer.
At the Dean Smith center, yeah, man
and that was huge, I was such a,
I mean, this is like, can't touch this,
so he's such a huge moment in pop music.
And you know, I was huge MC Hammer fan,
you were, you liked him
but I had completely drunk the Kool-Aid.
Something about yeah, 'cause.
I didn't understand how much of a,
how not good his music was
compared to all the rest of the
hip hop that was being made.
Oh yeah, because we were.
I was just a little Southern white boy
that didn't really understand it.
Yeah, we were 13 years old
and it, I mean, everybody loved MC Hammer,
he was a pop icon, he
wasn't a hip hop icon.
Yeah, it was a different thing.
And it, the hiphop community was going,
was coming after him.
They were rapping about
him and making fun of him
and I was like, why are
they after MC Hammer?
Well just another point of reference
to kind of bring this
into complete clarity,
Vanilla Ice was touring with him,
so, I mean, there weren't
many hip hop artists
who were gonna let
Vanilla Ice open for them.
And En Vogue.
Vanilla Ice did not show up that night,
we found out when we got
there and I was so upset.
Well, I think we were more
excited about Vanilla Ice,
to be honest with you, at that time.
I mean, just think about
that, it's En Vogue,
Vanilla Ice and MC hammer.
It's a big night and my mom.
And your mom was there, Sue was there.
My mom and my mom was into
it, she was loving it.
But Vanilla Ice didn't show up
but En Vogue really brought it.
What a man, what a man,
what a mighty good man.
I remember feeling things.
I don't remember a lot about
the show but it was huge,
it was like a big stage production,
it was like the biggest
thing I've ever seen.
Many years later, you and I went and saw
the Stone Temple Pilots
at the Dean Smith Center
as sophomores in college
and that was a, that show,
I remember that show sounding really good.
Yeah, that music sounded
great in that venue.
For it to be four guys just playing,
I mean they were, it
was really impressive.
And not just that,
four guys and one of them is
just singing, I mean, the.
One guitarist.
The guitarist in that band
doing a show like that,
yeah, it's crazy impressive.
The guitarist and bassist were brothers,
the DeLeo brothers or something,
so they were, yeah, they brought it, man,
I was, that's the first
time I went to a show
and I was paying attention to the sound,
this actually sounded good
and I remember our
friend Josh wanted to go
but for some reason we didn't invite him,
I don't know, sorry Josh,
still a little bit of an.
Was it the Brooks and Dunn
concert at Walnut Creek?
So, we saw a number of
acts at Walnut Creek,
including Van Halen,
which we weren't even
fans of, just because.
That wasn't our idea, we
saw George Strait there
and we all got in the, Joey
Smith drove his dad's suburban
and it was like nine of us in the suburban
and we were in the very back
and we were going to George Strait,
so we were cowboyed up,
we might have been wearing cowboy hats,
definitely cowboy shirts
and we were doing dip in the back.
In the back of a suburban,
not a great idea.
And I got so sick.
You gotta wait till you
get to the concert to dip
but was that the, which concert was it
that somebody had tequila?
That was it, it was Brooks and Dunn,
so there was this huge tailgating thing
happening in the parking lot
and I, we were just 16, 17 years old
and I'd never, we'd never been to parties
where people are drinking
liquor and just raising hell
and it's like, so we're walking around
and I'm talking to people,
I'm like, these rednecks at their tailgate
turning up tequila bottles and I'm like,
what's up guys, Brooks and Dunn, woo.
It's like, this is my, I'm like, woo,
you would think that I was drunk
when I hadn't had a drink
and then once you start being
friendly with these people,
they're like, hey man, you want some,
you want a shot of tequila?
And I'm like, oh, you called my bluff,
I'm like, nah and then I
don't remember how it happened
but it was like but I'll eat the worm,
I think that was my response, it was like.
I'll eat a worm though.
I'm not gonna.
I'm not approved.
You're calling my bluff,
I'm not actually going to drink
but I will eat the worm 'cause
and he was like, all right and he got the.
Get that boy the worm.
He got the worm out of the
bottom of the tequila bottle
and I ate it.
Wasn't the first time
you've eaten the worms anus.
Yeah, it was the second
and it definitely wouldn't be the last,
who knew that I'd make an
entire career out of it?
You didn't eat the worm.
No, I actually don't believe
that I was present for that moment
because I remember hearing about it
and feeling uneasy about it,
'cause that was in that moment
where our friends were
beginning to kind of party
and we were still a member of the group
and kinda like what you're saying,
we never had prudish personalities,
like if you talked to us
and you hung out with us,
you wouldn't be like, these
guys are super straight edge.
I had a raise hell personality.
It's only when you put
us against the wall.
But a fundamentalist mentality.
Once, in terms of what we
actually did and didn't do.
A conservative, christian mentality.
And so when I heard that you drank,
when you ate the tequila worm,
I was, there was a part
of me that was like,
is that drinking?
I mean there is some tequila in that.
It was definitely this vibe of,
what is Link gonna do if I'm not around?
Yeah, I feel like I gotta be there
to keep him from falling.
But I just think the worm.
And always starts.
With a tequila, with a worm,
the first step is the worm.
Not typically, it did not taste good,
I mean, it probably tasted better
than if it wasn't soaked
in tequila for a few months
or however long that happens.
I think we saw Travis Tritt
there at Walnut Creek.
I went to Travis Tritt
with my dad, actually.
I have seen Travis Tritt in concert,
I mean, I have to assume
that it was Walnut Creek.
It was pretty good I remember,
I remember we went into
the Brooks and Dunn show
and that's where I
bought the license plate
that I put on the front of my truck
and I bought it as a joke,
I just wanna go on record and say,
buying a license plate that
says Brooks and Dunn was a joke,
it was irony and put it
on the front of my truck
but it was also like, I don't know, not.
Not at the same time,
that we lived like that
in a lot of ways.
And they had a karaoke booth out there
where all the tents were,
where you could get your food
and your merch and stuff,
they had a karaoke booth
and I went up there and I,
we both, didn't you sing too?
I sang Big City by Merle Haggard
and I remember people
would, people stopped
and started watching me sing it
because, oh, here's this 16
year old singing Merle Haggard,
I like this guy
and it really fed into
this redneck mentality.
I just don't have a, I don't remember.
It was fun to be a part of
and I was a huge Brooks and Dunn fan,
which is why we covered them.
The most memorable
concert experience though,
I think has to be sort of the Merle,
the string of Merle Haggard experiences,
starting at 16 when
we'd go down to see him.
At the Alabama Theater in Myrtle Beach.
In Myrtle Beach and then.
I had to miss a soccer game.
Is that, that's the night
when we followed the tour bus.
Yeah, I was a starter on the soccer team
and we drove my Nissan pickup,
probably with the Brooks
and Dunn license plate
on the front, all the way
down there to Myrtle beach
to watch the show and then we
were just gonna drive back,
I think 'cause I don't
think we got a hotel room.
No, of course not but he was
driving south after the show
and we, these stories,
kind of the string of
Merle Haggard's stories
are all told in detail in
the Book of Mythicality,
in one of the chapters
talking about being a fan,
because it kind of came full circle
that we followed him as a
kid, we saw him multiple times
including at Dorton Arena and then.
Always the youngest guys in the crowd.
It was these two teenage dudes
who were not with their dads.
Three decades.
There were some kids who were there
with grandparents or
whatever, dads but not us,
we were just there completely
sincerely into this thing
and then of course, as an adult,
having the opportunity
to meet him backstage
in that weird, I'm not
gonna tell the whole story
but we've told the story in detail
on Good Mythical Morning and
in the Book of Mythicality
but then finally.
Meeting him at a point
where we could see him.
Getting on the tour bus with him
and going to the back of the tour bus
and having him kind of sit there
with a towel around his neck,
clearly a 70 something year old man
exhausted from playing another night
and these two super fans coming back there
and just not knowing what to say
and being that moment
where you're just like,
we followed you, we
followed, when we were kids,
we followed you across the state line
and it's just so cool to get to meet you
and you've been so, you
just don't know what to say
to somebody who's been that influential
and he was just kinda like,
you could kind of see it on his eyes,
he's like, I've heard
this a million times,
all right, you got
something for me to sign?
Yeah, I'll sign this,
I'll sign your albums.
We got the albums hanging
up in our office right there
that he signed,
he misspelled your name
but then he corrected it.
He corrected it.
That was good, so I mean.
It's easy to do.
I'm glad that we're back
on the concert train
and it's about creating an experience,
bringing people with you and
then having an experience
with all the other people
that you don't know,
it's not but I think, it's
also not all fun and games
when you got people
not wanting to sit down
and people not wanting to
stand up, it ain't easy,
there's lots of things that could happen.
And I always forget about.
Lots of worms to be eaten.
I always forget about that element
of preparing yourself for this night
and then you're like, oh, well,
'cause the worst is when
you're next to somebody
who's just super drunk,
super drunk and super loud.
Spilling beer on you.
And then you're just like,
oh man, I can't, I'm not
gonna be able to enjoy this,
it's like going to a
movie theater and it's,
in a movie theater, if somebody's
being loud next to you,
you can just tell them to shut up,
in a concert, I'm not
gonna be the person that,
you don't, I'm not gonna
start a concert fight.
That's why you invite more people
and then you sit in the
middle of all of them,
that's how you do it.
It might be a good idea to get that.
The Greek.
I don't know about getting a season pass
as much as I'm just thinking,
between the Hollywood Bowl
and the Greek theater,
all the venues downtown
where the smaller bands come, basically.
That's the great thing about being in LA,
you know everybody's gonna come through.
Every weekend, almost
every night of the year,
you could probably go and see somebody
that you have some level
of familiarity with.
Yeah, including Paul McCartney,
he's coming to SoFi, I should
and we should go see him.
I mean but the reason
why I brought that up
is 'cause that's my,
I'm gonna give my rec,
I gotta stay in the music zone.
Another music documentary
I watched on a plane
coming back home, McCartney
3, 2, 1 is a mini series,
three episodes on Hulu,
it's just Rick Rubin and Paul McCartney
at Rick Rubin's, I think
he's at Rick Rubin's studio
but they're in a couple,
it's very intimate,
the cameras are really
far back and zoomed in
and they're just having this
very off the cuff conversation,
Rick has his, if you don't
know who Rick Rubin is that's,
I'd love to meet Rick Rubin,
I think I gotta put him on the list,
that would be freaking
awesome to meet him,
legendary producer.
He has his mixing tables, soundboard,
whatever you call it out there
and then he's playing Beatles
tracks and some Wings tracks
and just getting and then
Paul is just talking about
and they're adjusting the
levels and talking about it
and so to illustrate a point,
they isolate the vocals,
so he had the stems for all of
these Beatles and Wings songs
and it's like, they're not too long
and it's, I mean, it's the
opposite of the Get Back thing
if that's inacessible to you
but you're a, more of
a casual Beatles fan,
Paul talks about how he teaches people
to play the piano in one of them,
so each one is kind of
themed in a different way
and it's just, it's very loose and.
He teaches people who are
gonna be playing with him.
No, like if he was teaching
a kid how to play piano,
like a beginner.
Yeah, I was like, I mean,
my kids can play piano
but I still thought about
sending it to Lily who,
when we were talking about garage bands,
she's in a band, she
just went back to school
and I was like, you getting
together with your band,
you guys are playing?
It's like, do you guys
wanna play in places?
And she's like, no, it's
just for the fun of it,
we might be putting
together a cover set list
and maybe something will happen
but it's like, it makes me
so happy that she's in a band
but 3, 2, 1, McCartney on Hulu,
well, it's called McCartney
3, 2, 1, check it out.
And we will speak with you next week,
I'll be telling you all
about my recent road trip
from Maine to Miami.
For real man, I've been
waiting to hear about it,
you can't tell me yet, so next week.
Ear Biscuits.
Hashtag Ear Biscuits.
To watch more Ear Biscuits,
click on the playlist on the right.
To watch the previous
episode of Ear Biscuits,
click on the playlist to the left.
And don't forget to click
on the circular icon
to subscribe.
If you prefer to listen to this podcast,
it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms,
thanks for being your mythical best.